what did you do before stand up oh okay
i was a businessman
uh i worked in tax services you worked
in tax services yes what did you do
in tax services i i was one i wore uh i
think
a lady liberty outfit
did you really yeah you were dressed as
lady liberty
and you were out in front of a place
that did taxes yeah and i have a sign
and uh it's my job to get people to
notice the place and
i got them to notice i would think yes
if i saw you as lady liberty i would
that would get my attention was it a bad
job i mean
that was good i mean first of all like
you said i got to dress up me dress up
as lady liberty i was like oh this is a
neo-nazis nightmare
so i loved it and it was fun i mean i
ended up getting a mrsa
from that's a serious skin disease
how did you get that well there's only
two or three outfits and there's about
10 to 12
employees so you're good
wait so you got really sick by wearing
that costume how much work did you miss
i missed uh i spent a couple years ago
valentine's day weekend
spent that in the icu and uh
got out and it was like hey can i still
work here
you you wanted to go back and work there
i'm a trooper conan yeah
i'm not going to let just the
flesh-eating virus stop me
so that they they must i'm sure they
were like very appreciative that you
no they had already they already found
somebody
oh god hey i got to ask you quickly you
were a gang member
you played a gang member in get hard and
i thought you did a terrific job
but you don't seem like a tough guy when
you know when i've seen you perform and
when i've talked to you and here tonight
you don't seem like a tough guy but it
seems like you really tried i think we
have a photograph of you
it seems like you really tried to get
into the role of a gangster in this film
oh that was that's just my home pictures
hey
[Applause]
yeah that's just uh no i'm not a tough
guy i'm kind of the opposite i think the
term for it is punk ass
i'm not that tough of a person yeah in
fact when i i got the job the first day
uh i get hard
yeah get hard i went in with wardrobe
and i was talking to the lady for a few
minutes we're just talking and she was
just like
ah i don't take this wrong but i don't
see you as a gang member
so i slapped her you know
yeah i'm sure he did
you don't believe me hey somehow somehow
ron i don't believe you slept
i'm sure what ended up happening with
you unless it was like this
uh you played too rough i'm sorry yeah